jungin ou un [ __ ] de président,
elle nous a payés pour certains des dommages
qu'ils ont causés zéro symptôme maintenant je
n'ai pas eu de dit non j'ai testé je teste
tous les deux jours ils veulent me tester
vous savez pour des raisons évidentes je veux dire  Je
suis le président là-bas donc ils veulent
me tester Je ne veux pas être testé mais
ils veulent me tester donc tous les deux
jours je me fais tester et j'ai été j'ai
montré toujours négatif bien négatif c'est
que le terme  vous utilisez pour ce droit
négatif totalement négatif aucun symptôme non
rien
j'ai dit ouais j'aimerais ça j'aimerais le
prendre beaucoup de gens ont pris beaucoup de
travailleurs de première ligne qui prennent
beaucoup d'hydroxychloroquine avant bien je
ne le fais pas  prenez-le parce que hé les gens ont dit oh
peut-être qu'il est propriétaire de l'entreprise non je ne connais pas
l'entreprise vous savez ce que je veux que
les gens de cette nation se sentent bien je
ne veux pas qu'ils soient malades et il y a de
très bonnes chances que cela ait  un impact
surtout au début donc je prends
le zinc et l'hydroxy et tout  Je peux
vous dire que jusqu'à présent, je semble aller bien il y
a quelques semaines, j'ai commencé à le
prendre parce que je pense que c'est bien, j'ai
entendu beaucoup de bonnes histoires et si ce n'est pas
bien, je vous le dirai bien, je ne le suis pas  va
être blessé par ça qu'est-ce que tu as à perdre d'
accord qu'est-ce que tu as à perdre alors hé mec
si je le prends depuis environ une
semaine chez moi depuis environ une semaine et demie
à un moment donné tous les jours je prends une pilule
tous les  jour ça fait 40 ans que
je veux y réfléchir donc je ne le connais pas
jamais entendu parler de lui mais ils m'ont demandé de le
licencier j'ai le